and the Oscar goes to
Michelle Young
[Applause]
[Music]
Michelle Yo's mom in tears watching her
daughter make Oscar's history it's a
historical win and just hope that I'm
not the last this is just the beginning
the malaysian-born star won best actress
for her portrayal as Evelyn Wang in
everything everywhere all at once oh oh
my God we forgot my father making
Michelle the first Asian woman to ever
win in the category what do you remember
most about tonight when they called my
name and when her name was called
Michelle's mom back home in Malaysia
cried tears of joy
I have to dedicate this
to my mom she's 84 and I'm taking this
home to her she's watching right now in
Malaysia KL with my family and friends
I love you guys I'm bringing this home
to you Michelle shared this sweet face
time with her afterwards
God
to make the moment even more special
Halle Berry presented Michelle with her
Oscar Hallie was of course the first
woman of color to win the category in
2001. Michelle now the second how are
you gonna celebrate look I'm here with
my family and friends yes I have a whole
group of friends who are so happy for me
so we are going to celebrate and stuff
Dance the Night Away there is lots to
celebrate it was a big night for
Michelle and her fellow castmates and
the Oscar goes to Jamie Lincoln
[Applause]
everything everyone
the film topped this year's Oscar
nominations with 11 and ended up taking
home seven seven out of 11.
and tonight we freaking broke that glass
ceiling
I converted out and shattered it
and we need this because there are so
many who have felt unseen unheard it's
not just the Asian Community this is for
the Asian Community but for anybody
who's been identified as a minority we
deserve to be heard we deserve to be
seen we deserve to have the Equal
Opportunity so we can have a seat at the
table
foreign
[Music]